I spent
$500 on this a typewriter and in this
video I'm going to walk through why I
bought it the pros and the cons and if
you should buy it too let's Dive Right
In actually before we Dive Right In if
you are a copywriter I have a free gift
for you in the link in the description
below copyrighting Catalyst my 63 cash
Cal copyrighting tips guaranteed to make
you some handsome profit for
free is in there all you got to do is
click the link give me your email tell
me where to send it and I will get it in
your inbox today so you can start going
through it and understanding the
fundamentals of copyrighting at a new
level I appreciate this support and I
can't wait for you to have it all right
let's dive back into the video the $500
typewriter that's been making a splash
all over the internet in fact I posted
it and my Twitter feed has been going
nuts I emailed my list and I even got a
response from the Daniel throssel who
then bought it and emailed his list and
it's been a fiasco of people copywriter
specifically in fact I believe that me
El Copo was the first copywriter ever to
buy the free R traveler which is the
name of the typewriter that I did buy
now let me dive into why I bought this
typewriter the reason I bought it is
honestly because I pulled up my phone
and I was a little bit disgusted with my
screen time I had a particularly heavy
week and I was racking up 10 to to 12
hours of screen time per day and it just
honestly added up in a way that didn't
make me feel warm and fuzzy inside and
it hit me where I was like man I really
just want to enjoy more moments that
have focus and I can breathe and there's
not all these tabs open and I'm not
looking at a screen all day so I
literally Googled typewriter 2024 I was
literally going to go from typing pen to
paper and then take a picture of it and
have like chat GPT or something trans
describe it to an email for me or
whatever that was my plan and then I
came across the free right traveler as
soon as I Googled 2024 typewriter I saw
a bunch of searches for this really cool
typewriter I didn't even know existed so
basically what it is it's a smart
typewriter with an e in screen meaning
the display is very Kindle esque you
look at it and it's easy on the eyes and
reads very much like paper and the only
thing that you can do on it is write
that's it there's no add there's nothing
you just open it up hit new you write a
new document and Bam you could send it
to your laptop because it has
connectivity via Wi-Fi that's the only
technology this thing has but I'm going
to get into that via the pros and cons
but before we go any further I do want
to clarify they did not send me this
typewriter they have not paid me to make
this video and they have not influenced
my thoughts in any way I pay for the
free right out of my pocket my own money
and these thoughts are 100 100% my own
let's dive into the pros the first pro
is it's
incredibly wellmade honestly when you
pick it up it feels very smooth feels
very high quality a nice aluminum finish
it does have plastic on it as well but
it feels excellent sturdy great size it
is a fullsize keyboard the clickety
clack on the keyboard is wonderful it
types amazing so truly the experience is
great and I really thought about this
because because I did see alternate
smart typewriters like the neo2 but it
just looked like a piece of crap
honestly it looked like just garbage
from the 80s it didn't look like it
would be fun it was big bulky chunky
after using the free Rite for about a
month and a half now the riding
experience is Sublime it's absolutely
wonderful I enjoy typing on this thing
so much that it is by far my favorite
and most focused riding experience the
second Pro is the E Inc display this was
the whole reason I bought it anyway was
to get away from like an LCD bright 4K
screen I wanted a nice e in display and
this one absolutely delivers it's truly
beautiful truly simple it's big enough
to read but nice and small to where you
can just enjoy the tight experience I
truly enjoy the eing display and it'll
get you hours of screen time away from
your writing habits the third Pro is the
Simplicity and the technology honestly
after you get it set up which takes you
about an hour to connect to your Google
Drive and things like that it's got a
button on the keyboard where after
you've written your draft you can
literally just tap send and it goes
straight to your Google Drive and
straight to your email which is a
perfect workflow for me because then I
can just go grab it out of my email put
it in my notion or my Apple notes
whatever give it a nice edit and then
slay it in to go ahead and send us an
email because obviously I'm an email
copywriter so most of the content that
I'm writing on here is emails and the
biggest Pro of all is that it does
nothing but
typ that's it you could just open up a
new document and start typing there's no
apps there's no nothing on here all you
can do is focus and I got to say I've
had some of my most heavy perfect deep
focus flow sessions off of this thing
because I've been able to just put my
headphones on you know turn some music
on on my phone throw my phone in my bag
and go go to town typeing on this thing
and I've got no tabs open no messages
popping up it's just pure Bliss of focus
and it is probably the biggest Pro of
all let's get to some of the cons the
first con being it's expensive as you
read in the title it is a
$500 typewriter and that is not
including if you get a sleeve or
anything like that I mean for 500 bucks
you could technically buy like a
Chromebook or one of those like small
notebook laptops that that does
everything but type but again that's not
the focus of what this does this is for
writers who are looking for a lot more
focus and a lot more Simplicity in their
writing habits the next con is that
editing on this thing is horrible this
thing is not for editing I mean
technically you can you could do like
the shift and page up and page down and
try and find your word but it's not tap
display you can't like use a cursor oh
it's horrible editing on it is
horrendous I've tried to edit on it and
then I just realized no not a chance
honestly half the time if I don't free
flow an entire document I'll like
probably just end up starting a new
document starting from scratch but it's
also forced me to just honestly write
and edit separately which I was already
doing but now this is just to a new
level where it's like just focus on
writing send it to your laptop edit it
in notion or Google Docs later call it a
day the third con is it does have a
slight lag from your typing so you type
a little and it takes a millisecond to a
second to actually show up on the screen
which by the way does not bother me I
barely notice it especially after a
couple days but I've heard people in the
comments where I've posted it on Twitter
and talked about it via my email where
people are like the lag would drive me
nuts honestly I don't think it's as bad
as it is but I do have to mention it
because I think it would bother other
people more than it bothers me and the
last con is the formatting it doesn't
have any formatting or emojis or
anything like that which if you're on my
email list and you read my emails my
emails are really fun I use like a two
headlines to break up the text I use
bullet points I do italics markdowns
bolts all this stuff and it does cost
more editing on the back end but again
this is for smooth drafts on the front
end but it is a con to not be able to do
it up front those are my pros and cons
now let me tell you who I would
recommend this for I would recommend
this for anybody that already has a
daily riding habit built if you are now
just getting into writing or you want to
start a daily writing habit and you
think that buying this $500 writing tool
will motivate you enough to do it I just
wouldn't recommend it for me I've
already built a 1 to 2 hour per day
daily writing habit where 1,000 to 2,000
words per day is not uncommon at all and
I was trying to solve a problem of
screen time and focus right if those are
not your problems and you just want to
build a daily writing habit just do it
on your iPad or on your MacBook justify
that this is something you're going to
stick with in the long term before you
make a massive investment like this
otherwise if you already have a daily
writing habit then yes I would recommend
this and the reason I would recommend it
is because you're going to be putting
hours per day not on a screen and you're
going to have way more focus and to me
that's worth 500 bucks because at the
end of the year you're going to rack up
600 to 1,000 hours that would have been
on your MacBook that would have been on
your phone that would have been on your
iPad writing content and you're going to
be way more distracted your content's
not going to be as good and I guarantee
you're not going to get as much writing
done I've gotten way more writing done
I've truly enjoyed the process I've
upgraded one to two hours a day of my
life just enjoying the writing process
even more and that to me is tremendously
worth it highly recommend it wanted to
get the word out for you guys and I'd
love to know what questions do you have
about the Free Ride traveler drop them
in the comments below I'd love to answer
them for you that wraps us up for
today's video I hope that you enjoyed it
and if you did please it would mean the
world to me for you to like the video
and subscribe to the channel to know
that you want more content on
copyrighting learning how to be a
copywriter the best tools how to make
money copyrighting everything
copyrighting I'd love to help you but I
can't do that unless you subscribe to
the channel and don't forget your free
gift copyrighting Catalyst on the way
out hope this has been really beneficial
really helpful to you I appreciate you
more than you know and I will catch you
on the next video
is